I can't.
This is an expression that is vilified
in our minds beginning at a young age.
Every time a young child announces
this decision, they are corrected.
The first adult that hears it, ask them
whether or not they have even tried.
Generally this confrontation will result
in the child giving their task another
attempt until they're attention
span moves on to something else.
The adult will see this and chocolate to
themselves with knowledge that this is
just a child who is yet to learn the
art of art and virtue of perseverance.
By the time this child
comes of age, however,
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count that there
is no such thing as can't.
It is interesting then to think about
how many adults seem to proclaim this
expression in their lives. It is because,
is it because like many things
that adults tell children,
they are simply telling the
child a general rule that
the child must follow but
can be broken once one is grown or
has it because these adults are simply
repeating what they were told as children
without thoroughly examining what the
phrase I can't truly suggests.
If you confronted an adult that claims
they can't do something with the same
question about whether
or not they have tried,
the answer will almost always be yes.
Adults have learned enough to know that
it is unreasonable to say they can't
until they have at least
tried once. Therefore,
the real question that we
should be asking and responses,
have you tried everything?
Have you exhausted every possible
option, scenario, combination,
tool and approach?
I do not simply refer to the ones that
you knew of at the time you decided to
undertake your task.
I mean have you re also researched
possibilities that you had known about?
Have you determined whether or not there
is another person out there that has
performed the exact same task you are
attempting or at least something similar?
Have you exhausted this research? Have
you read every book, blog, Journal,
magazine, bathroom stall and website?
If the answer to any of these questions
is no, then go back and try again.
Because if you don't,
because you don't truly know if you
can do something until you've tried
absolutely everything.
The fact of the matter
is that rarely if ever,
is the answer to all of
these questions. Yes.
Therefore, what is it that people
actually mean when they say,
I can't a more accurate but more
verbose way of saying it would be,
I don't care about or want enough this
task or the resultant benefits of it in
order to do all that is
necessary to achieve it.
Okay.
I was told countless numbers of times
by people during my month of marathons
that they couldn't run one
marathon, let alone 30 straight.
Every now and then when I had time
I would discuss what they'd said.
We would jointly conclude
that if something they
cared about and dependent on
them doing so, it would be possible.
The most common example I used was if
someone had a gun to your child's head,
do you think you could
do it? Then therefore,
the phrase I can't denotes a lack of
investment as opposed to a lack of
potential or ability.
I do not mean to say that every person
I had this conversation with should have
had the motivation to run marathons.
It was something that I decided to do,
not them. I merely wanted to express
to them what I am expressing here.
Given the right purpose
and enough time you can.
What happens if someone
has said they can't?
We have asked them if they've
done everything and the
rare cases happen and they
honestly say yes. Do we concede
that then they can't? Nope.
If everything in existence
has been attempted enough
to determine that it won't
work, then congratulations.
You've been awarded the honor of being
the person who must invent the method or
the tool or determine the right
combination, whether or not you will.
Once again boils down to
how much you care and time.
It may end up being that a person
ends up trying for their entire life,
but I suggest removing the phrase I
can't from your lexicon and replacing it
with, I can't yet.
Okay,
do this so that you don't risk
being on your death bed saying,
I didn't.